that's a good one to get wrong that's a
good piece of trivia
it's our dilophosaurus
a rattlesnake swans swans wow the the
clicking
that's pretty cool
so i'm gonna say that was um blue
hey
yay okay that's good
it's really tough like it's blowing out
the speaker a little bit so it could be
the t-rex or the indominus it's going to
be one of those two though oh you see
diamonds yeah
um i feel like
instead of a baby elephant it would be
like an adult elephant
it's like louder i know the komodo
dragons don't make a sound though the
baby elephants is right and i'm gonna
call it as partially true
ah okay yeah very tricky true false
question
[Music]
it would be an ankylosaurus big spiky
tail and the armor and it's just such a
cool uh looking tank of a creature but
it's got a little soft belly so you you
know that it's you know it's kind and
vulnerable i think i would probably have
to say diplodocus they're like the tall
one with the big neck they seemed so
friendly and i'd even though they're
kind of huge i don't think they'd eat me
because they're herbivores so my life
would not be at risk which is kind of a
pro if you're gonna adopt a dinosaur
you